une vingtaine d'exposants réunis pour un
même but sensibiliser les petites
entreprises du territoire au numérique
un enjeu primordial aujourd'hui pour
mieux développer son activité
c'est ce qui a conduit la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat des yvelines et
l'association france gestion a organisé
ce premier forum
l'évolution va très très vite
actuellement et on a l'impression que
les artistes ne se rendent pas compte de
l'utilité de ces outils qui peut être
très utile pour leur métier
je fais de la communication chez as it
gets facebook j'ai instagram je fais pas
mal de choses c'est j'avais besoin de
poivre si je devais m'améliorer sur quel
point je devais travailler au programme
de la journée des ateliers des
démonstrations avec des casques de
réalité virtuelle ou encore des
démonstrations de drones c'est un outil
qui est un objet un objet connecté qui
peut vraiment servir pour nos
entreprises
prenez l'exemple du bâtiment pour faire
des cartographies voir comment elle
seule une déperdition de chaleur ou par
une centaine de tpe et blinoise était
attendue la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat des yvelines souhaite d'ores
et déjà pérenniser cette manifestation